[Musique]
c'est important parce que nous avons des
défis comme disait dans la libéralie
mais les défis quand nous faisons face à
ces défis ensemble comme nous le faisons
aux États-Unis le Canada on va avoir un
succès un succès pronostic citoyens mais
aussi à succès pour ces pays à travers
le monde la guerre en Ukraine la crise
en Haïti le soulèvement populaire en
Iran et les relations avec la région
Indo-Pacifique était à Londres du jour
des discussions dans le cadre de la
visite au Canada du secrétaire d'État
américain Anthony blinken ça fait des
mois que l'on attend du gouvernement
Trudeau une vision claire sur la façon
dont il envisage l'avenir de ses
relations avec la grande région
Indo-Pacifique alors que la Chine Pandi
infirmière son emprise c'est Mélanie
Joly qui avait le mandat d'élaboré cette
stratégie je retrouve la ministre des
Affaires étrangères à Montréal madame
Joly merci d'être avec nous bonjour
Daniel bon avant de parler de la
stratégie Indo-Pacifique j'aimerais vous
entendre sur Haïti parce que ça ça a été
un une grosse partie des conversations
avec Monsieur blinken cette semaine
on a l'impression que la situation sur
le terrain commence à rendre une
intervention à étrangère inévitable à
quel moment est-ce que ça devient à peu
près incontournable pour le Canada de se
pointer la premièrement la situation en
Haïti présentement les catastrophique
donc ça fait plus de 40 jours que le
terminal vaux qui est le terminal ou
normalement les dans le fond les
produits l'eau potable
l'essence les biens de base
c'est à travers ce terminal là que
normalement les choses sont acheminées
il est bloqué il est en fait pris en
otage par les gangs et donc ça fait en
sorte que les hôpitaux qui fonctionnent
à partir de génératrices ne peuvent pas
fonctionner il y a une épidémie de
choléra qui fait en sorte que des
enfants qui meurent tous les jours
présentement en Haïti bref la population
souffre énormément et certainement on
doit agir ouais mais c'est ça mais
qu'est-ce que c'est le geste lequel
l'ONU dit il est peut-être temps et le
gouvernement haïtien a dit une force
d'intervention étrangère serait la
bienvenue sur le terrain on sent qu’en
réticence du côté canadien aller dans
cette direction là à quel moment est-ce
que la ligne est franchie quand il faut
y aller mais il y a deux choses
premièrement on a envoyé une mission
d'évaluation sur le soleil ici pour
savoir quel état quel est l'état de la
de la situation les équipes sont là et
donc j'aurai leur rapport au cours des
prochains jours première chose deuxième
chose c'est sûr que pour nous la
question de la légitimité d'intervention
elle est très importante c'est important
qu'il y ait plusieurs pays qui soit
impliqués pour assurer la sécurité de
Haïti parce qu'à haïti fait face à trois
crises premièrement une crise de
sécurité je vous ai viens de vous parler
du terminal vaux deuxièmement une crise
humanitaire et troisièmement une crise
de d'une crise politique parce que on
sait le président jovenel Moïse a été
assassiné il y a maintenant un an et
demi le président Henri est là en place
mais il y a toujours pas d'élections
démocratique donc on doit s'attaquer à
ces trois crises-là et c'est pourquoi
j'ai eu plusieurs conversations avec mes
homologues là-dessus mais c'est pourquoi
aussi le Canada on va aller encore plus
loin on a jamais sanctionné les élites
qui profitent de la violence dans les
rues de Port-au-Prince et à travers
Haïti on n'a jamais été aussi loin que
de coordonner avec les États-Unis
d'autres pays pour justement sanctionner
sur ceux qui sont les oligarques
haïtiens et certainement c'est notre
objectif d'aller de l'avant c'est une
recommandation de l'ONU qui était
adoptée il y a quelques jours déjà donc
vous allez dans cette direction là
est-ce qu'il y aura des ressortissants
ici installées au Canada qui vont être
ciblés par vos par vos sanctions parce
que c'est ce que l'on souhaite on
souhaite les gens sur le terrain en
Haïti mais les gens qui financent et
appuient les gens sur le terrain aussi
est-ce qu'il y a des Canadiens qui vont
faire partie de vos listes l'impunité
n'est pas une option c'est la chose que
je peux dire à votre question et puis ce
que je vous dirais aussi que notre
régime de sanction le but c'est qu'il
soit efficace donc certainement si
jamais il y a des personnes au Canada
qui font partie dans le fond de ce
système de corruption qui profite de la
violence en Haïti certainement ils vont
être sanctionnés est-ce que vous avez
des gens dans le collimateur ce qui a
des Canadiens que vous ce que vous
connaissez ou que vous soupçonnez de
soutenir des gangs en Haïti écoutez mon
objectif c'est pas de vous donner la
stratégie gouvernementale sur la
question dans le cadre de l'entrevue
mais je vous donne l'intention du
gouvernement donc certainement le but
c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'impunité et
qu'on travaille avec d'autres pays parce
que au final on doit s'assurer que la
crise politique puisse être résolue et
ça passe nécessairement par des
sanctions envers les élites haïtiennes
qui sincèrement profite pendant qu'il y
a des gens des gens qui meurent dans les
rues d'Haïti j'aimerais vous parler
maintenant de j'aimerais qu'on discute
un peu de la Stratégie canadienne face à
la région Indo-Pacifique c'est dans
votre lettre de mandat c'est vous qui en
avez la responsabilité on l'attente
qu'un bout de temps pourquoi on n'a pas
encore ces stratégies entre les mains
mais parce que c'est important de
travailler avec aussi les experts à
travers le pays qui connaissent
l'Indopacifique j'ai créé un Comité sur
l'Indopacifique
environ au mois de juin dernier et puis
et puis ils me sont revenus avec leur
recommandation au cours de l'été je leur
ai parlé à plusieurs reprises et d'ici
la fin d'année la stratégie
sera certainement dévoilé notre objectif
est encore et toujours de défendre et
promouvoir nos intérêts canadiens dans
la région de Pacifique on est un pays de
l'into Pacifique on est un pays avec une
très grande côte pacifique mais je
pensais important maintenant qu'on joue
un plus grand rôle ça veut dire quoi un
plus grand rôle du Canada dans cette
région là
l'avenir du monde va jouer en grande
partie dans la région de l'Asie qu'on
appelle l'Indopacifique et il y a une
grande partie de commerce international
aussi qui se passe dans cette région là
d'ailleurs dans les plus grands
partenaires de commerce international du
Canada
on retrouve le Japon la Corée du Sud
bref de pays où j'étais encore récemment
qui sont de grands partenaires et avec
qui on veut encore plus intensifié notre
notre partenariat et puis certainement
on sait que des enjeux de sécurité dans
la région donc on doit s'assurer de
jouer un plus grand rôle au niveau de la
sécurité de la paix de la stabilité dans
la région donc
notre objectif c'est justement d'avoir
une plus grande présence vous vous citer
le Japon la Corée du Sud je n'ai pas
entendu le nom Chine de votre bouche
est-ce que vous envisagez une reprise
même timide des relations avec la Chine
ou est-ce que c'est exclu à l'heure
actuelle nous avons des relations avec
la chaîne premièrement j'ai eu des
discussions avec mon homologue douanier
le ministre des Affaires étrangères
chinois et chaque jour les gens à
travers le pays bénéficient des produits
qui proviennent de la Chine il y a des
relations entre
canadien sont tendus les relations entre
le Canada et la Chine depuis l'affaire
des deux micros c'est sûr qu'elles ont
été beaucoup plus tendu depuis les deux
mailles call c'est sûr aussi que la
chaîne est un pays présentement qui a
une rectorique très agressive pas juste
envers le Canada mais en verre plusieurs
pays et la Chine ne respecte pas toutes
les normes liées au droit international
donc on est très proche et c'est sûr
qu'on va contester leur position
lorsqu'ils ne respectent pas les règles
qui ont sincèrement vraiment assuré
l'aspect la stabilité depuis la Deuxième
Guerre mondiale donc on est capable de
collaborer avec ce géant de l'Asie mais
en même temps on doit naviguer cette
relation là avec les yeux grands ouverts
et c'est mon objectif en tant que chef
de la diplomatie canadienne est-ce que
ça veut dire une prise de position ferme
concernant Taïwan
mais pour nous la question de Taïwan
essentiellement c'est on a des relations
avec Taïwan parce que on a certainement
des relations commerciales d'ailleurs on
veut approfondir ces relations là mais
en même temps ce qui nous préoccupe
c'est le détroit entre le Taiwan et la
Chine et c'est pour ça que il y a une
frégate canadienne qui est passée à
travers le détroit de Taïwan récemment
pour établir que c'est un détroit c'est
un une zone navigable internationale et
c'est important qu'elle le demeure ainsi
parce que 50% du commerce dans la région
de l'Indo-Pacifique passe par cette voie
navigable et c'est important qu'elle
demeure internationale
merci infiniment d'avoir été
ça grand plaisir passe une bonne journée